hey guys Pete here today I have a new
dark video this is an idea that's been
requested in the comments of my season 3
videos and it kind of blew me away when
I put it all together people have been
asking about the path of the different
objects through the timeline so today
I'm gonna detail one of them the st.
Christopher pendant its path in season 2
was something I had already detailed in
my notes when I made the video for
Jonases journey through time as I was
watching season 3 I almost dropped the
idea because it gets a lot more
complicated but then I realized it
actually presents an opportunity people
have been posing a lot of questions
about the split reality dependent
travels through them and ends up in
different places so by following the st.
Christopher's path it might actually
help clear things up a really quick
spoiler warning I'm gonna be talking
about things that happen throughout the
Netflix series dark and if you haven't
completed all three seasons then this
video won't be for you feel free to come
back after you finish the series though
because believe me you'll have questions
st. Christopher is the patron saint of
travelers according to Christian legend
he earned that title by carrying a child
across the river he didn't know it at
the time but the child revealed himself
as Christ when they got to the other
side this reinforced Christopher's faith
which later he was asked to renounce and
he wouldn't so he was beheaded and thus
he became a martyr
darhk's st. Christopher pendant depicts
him carrying the Christ child on his
shoulder a fun fact you might have
missed is that the church in bendin is
also called st. Christopher's which is
quite fitting for all the traveling that
goes on there what I find fascinating
about this artifact is that it
symbolizes the connection between yonus
and Marta this is a connection that
extends beyond the two teenagers we meet
in season 1 the connection exists across
multiple timelines multiple worlds and
multiple versions of the characters it's
woven into the story in a way that feels
like it's always been there but in
reality it didn't play a part in the
first season chronologically speaking
the pendant enters the story in 1954 and
that
well we'll start Aegon Tiedemann gives
it to Hannah Kahn Walt who's traveled
back in time from 2020 these two have a
hot affair going on but things go cold
quickly
Hannah finds out she's pregnant and at
this point Aegon still has a family at
home they split up and she initially
wants to have an abortion and it goes to
an abortion clinic where she meets a 12
year old named Hellena al bears they
strike up a conversation and at the end
of that Hannah changes her mind she
decides to have the baby because the
young girl mentioned liking the idea of
st. Christopher the idea of someone
carrying us on our journey someone
watching over us
Hannah leaves dependent behind four
Hellena keeps the pendant and wears it
for the next 33 years by the way she's
Katarina's mother and the next time we
see her wearing it is when her
time-traveling daughter arrives at her
place of work Katarina travelled back in
time
looking for her son and her husband she
actually uses the fact that she knows
about the pendant to get her mother to
let her see Ulrich she knows what it is
and she brings it up and of course her
mother doesn't recognize her because
she's 33 years older than the last time
she saw her things go terribly wrong for
Katarina from there she hatches a plan
to free her husband Ulrich that involves
taking her mother's keycard that leads
to a struggle where Katarina pulls the
pendant from Elaine's neck as she's
being beaten to death as her body is
being dragged into the lake the pendant
is left behind on the shore 32 years
later Caterina's children Magnus and
Marta are hanging out at the lake with
their friends Marta has a crush on yonus
and while they're talking on the beach
they find the pendant in the sand
yonis leaves abruptly just after that
leaving the pendant with Marta but
because this is the day before his
father's suicide there are two versions
of yonas at the lake the slightly older
version has just traveled back from 1921
to try to stop his father from taking
his own life which will also erase his
existence he takes this opportunity to
see Marta one last time
they have their first kiss just after he
tells her for the first time you and I
are perfect for each other
never believe anything else later that
night Marta gives the pendant which
she's put on a string back to the
younger version the yonus then they have
sex for the first time it's kind of
hilarious how this plays out since the
older version swooped in at the beach
and the kiss happened Marta is following
that feeling but yonas thinks she's
making the first move from there the st.
Christopher now has its meaning for
yonas and things get a little more
complicated from there at the beginning
of season two we see that yonas has it
in the bunker and 2053 I'm guessing that
he recovered it from his house after
being transported to the future from the
1980s it's possible that he was carrying
it with him but we never saw it since
that happened in season 1 everything
after that gets more complicated due to
the fact that the reality split
hopefully you've watched my previous
season 3 videos where I explained the
concept the show refers to as quantum
entanglement the idea is that ava uses
an exploit to split things into two
realities that exist simultaneously in
the first jana survives the apocalypse
by running into the basement
this is his path to becoming adam in
this reality he keeps the pendant with
him for the next 33 years as he lives in
the post-apocalyptic wounded this is the
time where Claudia is stalling from
stabilizing the god particle and he's
essentially stuck eventually he travels
back as the stranger and leaves the
pendant on Martha's pillow she thinks
this is a sign that her yonus has
returned and later goes to the con
walled house while she's there she runs
into the stranger for the first time he
mentions the pendant in the process of
getting her to realize who he is and she
winds up leaving it behind when Katarina
shows up so he gets the pendant back and
then as mentioned this is the version of
yonis where he becomes Adam and he keeps
the pendant with him until he grows old
in the reality where yonus is saved from
the apocalypse by Marta he takes the
pendant with him and this confuses
things even more
let me explain yonis who travels to
Martha's world always gets shot there
he's always got the pendant when he goes
there and as he's dying he gives the
pendant to the youngest version of Marta
the one who's wearing the yellow
raincoat her path then diverges though
in one outcome she rescues Jonas and
then leaves him in the cave in that
reality she goes back to 1888 to give
stranger yonas the caesium only to be
imprisoned by atom later in 2050 3 he
takes the st. Christopher she's wearing
in that reality before he kills her with
the god particle
so the path of that pendant ends there
and the other reality Martin never
rescues Jonas bartosh intervenes and
takes her back to Eva's this is the
version of Marta that grows old and in
this outcome Adam never gets the chance
to take the pendant back she keeps it
with her for the rest of her life to
recap things one version of the pendant
stays with the onus as he grows old to
become Adam due to Ava's quantum
entanglement manipulation another
version comes into her possession it's
given to the youngest version of her
though so there's another copy created
when the timeline is split one stays
with her until she grows old and becomes
Eva and the other is taken by Adam when
he kills her in that situation Adam
would then have two versions of the
pendant after meeting with Claudia Adam
changes things up again he rescues yonus
from the apocalypse creating a third
reality yonis then rescues marta from
the apocalypse in her world and if you
think about it both of them are now
carrying a st. Christopher pendant when
that happens he has the one that he
would keep until he grows old in that
reality and she has the one he gave her
as he was dying in her world so at the
end of the day there's basically five
different pendants out there in the
universe of course things change
dramatically when they do go to the
origin world but I think it's really
cool how they placed the pendant on its
path in the story the showrunner Bo odar
got one over on all
last year when he posted the photo of
Hannah wearing it this made us all think
that she would be the lady in the lake
that bartosh mentions while the teens
are swimming having Hannah pass it off
to Katerina's mom was an amazing twist
and ultimately the way it came to be on
the beach in that scenario is much more
tragic the st. Christopher always shows
up at emotionally-charged moments Hannah
gets it just before she learned she's
pregnant with cilia Elena gets it just
after she experiences something no
twelve-year-old should ever have - Jonas
and Marta first come into possession of
it at the exact location where her
mother was killed they find it just as
their ill-fated romance is about to
really begin and of course
alt Marta first gets it just after yonus
is killed right in front of her in a
story where the characters are unable to
let go dependence serves as a reminder
for all that they've been through I
think it's brilliant that all the main
versions of the characters that
connected end up with the st.
Christopher in their possession at the
end Adam and Eva both have at least one
when they disappeared together as does
yonus and Marta in the origin world and
with that I will leave you there let me
know in the comments what you think and
how'd you realize just how crazy the
pendens path was it's complicated so let
me know if you have any questions I
think the major thing to remember is
that yellow raincoat Marta getting it is
important since her path hasn't split
yet I'll be making a few other dark
videos this week so keep your questions
coming I've been keeping track and will
probably be answering some of them this
week please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching
I will talk to you soon